joining us from the mmqb right now with
the nfl just news of poppin um
albert breer joining us here once again
on the program how you doing albert
did i get you at a bad time i i like
when i left the house michigan was up by
like 15 or something no there it's now
yeah you got me at a bad time you got me
at a bad time right now
but it's a good time in terms of talking
about the national football league um
let's get into it here uh albert what
happened with the colts and wentz i mean
week 15 saturday night football
um they they crushed
they crushed it against new england
which had a furious comeback fall short
but
indianapolis looked like what the niners
looked like uh at the end of the season
and into the playoffs the proverbial
team nobody wanted to face and now it's
just like you know uh
whence you can't even say fell out of
favor there was no favor there was
nothing right right well i i i there are
two pieces of this i'm rich and you know
i like i i think frank rank is sort of a
neutral party here uh because he does
have the close relationship with wentz
um yeah i think the the the key figures
are chris ballard and
jim irsay i think from ballard's
standpoint it wasn't so much about the
way carson played over the course of 17
games
because i mean it wasn't great but like
i think you could kind of justify some
of it and like a lot of the stuff the
colt said before the year
which was if we're really good around
him he'll be fine came true now the end
of the year when they had to put a lot
on his shoulders he wound up falling
short but i think they were sort of
prepared for that right when jonathan
taylor
was making his mvp run lentz was
again not great but he was fine
um i think for ballard this was more
about the guy you want leading your room
right and kind of
whether or not that guy you can envision
him being like the battleship commander
for your organization going forward
and i think chris ballard discovered a
lot of the stuff that the eagles knew um
when they traded him to indy which was
he's not really that guy you know and he
doesn't relate great with teammates and
when things aren't good is he
accountable
um can we count on him when things are
really tough when we got to put the team
on his shoulders like how is he beyond
just how he plays like how is he going
to react to that emotionally and so i
think that the makeup part of it was
what ballard had
misgivings on now their say i think this
is more about a sense of urgency with
the court they've built and you look at
it they've done a really nice job over
the next last five years putting
something around whoever the
quarterback's going to be and remember
this is all meant for andrew luck right
like but quentin nelson darius leonard
julian blackman will come back off of
injury jonathan taylor michael pittman i
mean we're talking about you know guys
who are
you know kind of in the wheelhouse now
like this core
this should be when this group is
winning you know and i think that's part
of irsay's frustration now is three
years after um or two and a half i guess
two and a half years after andrew luck
retired
like the rest of the team is coming of
age as as they really wanted it to
and yet the quarterback position is
still a mess and
like i you know think the owner sort of
looked at it as what we've got isn't
good enough and i think it's fair to
look at it that way so to me as much as
anything else this is about a the makeup
of the player the makeup of carson wentz
and whether or not that was what they
wanted to build around and then b
the sense of urgency they really have to
have with the core group that they've
built over the last five years so if the
colts learn this the hard way if you
will and the eagles learned it the hard
way then why are the washington
commanders after saying they're gonna
you know they're they're gonna go yolo
and knock on everybody's door
why why do they go in this direction
why what do they do because they're out
of answers um you know look
realistically
like so they made a they made a real
pitch um russell wilson they offered
three first-round picks there
they
um you know they they they would have
taken a swing at aaron rodgers if aaron
rodgers had ever become available
and then the third quarterback that's a
big name here deshaun watson they like
him
but i mean i think for obvious reasons
this was sort of going to be a
non-starter for them because of
everything that their organization
has gone through over the last two years
and the workplace stuff and everything
else
unless there was full and complete
settlement of all the legal stuff not
just the criminal part all the legal
stuff
watson was going to be a non-starter for
them so that left them on the second
tier and i think with any of the
quarterbacks whether it was garoppolo
wentz whoever else
i think the way that they looked at it
was
if we do that it's probably going to be
multiple swings and so i think the way
you want to look at wence now is do they
think they can get a little more out of
them yeah because wentz has always been
a really good downfield thrower has he
ever had a guy quite like terry mclaurin
maybe not like so you know maybe there's
something there um at the very least
they're bringing in a guy who started a
lot of games who's seen a lot of things
and i don't think they're done at
quarterback my guess would be
they'll look very very hard at the idea
of drafting one in the first round now i
think what you can say because the money
is they're probably not going to take
another swing on a take a swing on
another veteran quarterback but i think
the idea they could take one in the
first round of the draft is very much
still alive so what's the colts plan at
quarterback what's that
um you know i that's that's the big
mystery here i mean
i i saw you know obviously our friend
ian like mentioned jimmy garoppolo the
other day
um you know i know florio mentioned uh
kirk cousins i'd be stunned if chris
ballard didn't pick up the phone and
call josh mcdaniels and dave ziegler
about derek carr
i mean maybe he asks them if there's
something creative that could happen
with derek carr going to indy and maybe
jimmy garoppolo going to vegas um you
know they have to think outside the box
like that you know and i i don't know
what the answer is because i mean you
know you were in indianapolis for a week
with the rest of us you know what the
league thinks of this quarterback class
coming in and they don't have a first
round pick to begin with
so like that's always been my thing with
the with the once thing with them rich
is like i mean yeah it sounds good like
but then what and i think they're still
sorting through the then what part of
the equation i mean short of the texans
being willing to trade deshaun watson
in the division
which i don't think they will
like what else is there for you out
there i'm not sure and you know again
like chris balor is good at this maybe
he's got a rabbit he's getting ready to
pull out of his hat but i do think
they're gonna have to to look at this
creatively because obviously right now
they don't have a whole lot of the
position right and certainly not enough
to get watson you could even make the
case that if watson does become viable
in any way shape or form that seattle
what it just got from
denver might not even be enough
for watson so
and you could basically say
that what you just saw for wilson
would be somewhere in that neighborhood
of what it would take to get derek carr
right i mean don't you think yeah i mean
i like even take it to whence rich i
mean i thought like when when we started
hearing about wence like
i i honestly thought like a month ago
like like is this going to be like a
brock osweiler salary dump you know what
i mean like i i just didn't think that
the i didn't think the colts be able to
find somebody to take on the money
forget the rest of it you know what i
mean and so
um you know the fact that wence brought
that home i mean
john lynch has to feel pretty good about
where he's at with jimmy garoppolo you
know what i mean like even though
garoppolo is um you know garoppolo is is
you know coming back from shoulder
surgery and you know then if derek carr
is worth you know what a one and a three
or something like that
like would that get the raiders to think
about it and again like with that idea
of uh a swap like a all right like we'll
we'll send carr off and then we'll bring
in jimmy garoppolo would that appeal to
one and i don't know that it would
because i do think like that josh
mcdaniels and dave ziegler i think
they're being sincere when they say they
really like dairy card it was really
important for josh to get off to the
right foot get that kind of get that
relationship off to the right foot with
derrick carr after what happened you
know when he started in denver
uh you know but if you're thinking
creatively about this like that's that's
the way you have to start thinking if
you're chris ballard you know because i
just there isn't an easy answer out
there again short of maybe the
the texans being willing to trade them
in division and even if the texans were
willing to do that you don't have a
first round pick to to to deal with them
you know so it's a it's i think it's a
tricky spot uh for the coal schools to
be in without question and uh i'll tell
you this rich that ghost of andrew luck
seems to be continuing to haunt
indianapolis and i've got albert breer
here on the rich eisen show so we had
andrew brant on in our number one
colleague of yours
and he's like i need to see the contract
before i believe aaron rodgers is
uh attached at the packers hip for the
rest of his career that
this might just be essentially a cap
clearing
um
solution to him running it back one more
time with devonte adams for him to get
to his free you know walk if you will
year that he negotiated to come back
last year
what do you think
well i mean i the one thing i had heard
was that there were and you know like i
i know um you know there was
the idea out there this would be a
four-year deal i heard it was four new
years and that's interesting to me
because
um if it's four new new year's that
means it's a five-year deal right now
essentially and that number is the magic
number five years
is the max that you can spread that
bonus money out over right so that's
being done for a reason and a lot of
times like those five-year deals will
have phony years in the back end so
you know when i when i heard that it
wasn't just it wasn't a four-year deal
as a four-year extension
like that popped in my head okay like
are there phony years in the back end
that are designed to spread the cap hit
out i think it's aaron's intention to
finish his career in green bay i don't
have any reason to think otherwise i
think he's got an appreciation for the
guys he plays with and all the rest of
it like i think this is a big i mean to
me like this is happening because of
aaron rodgers relationships because he
felt as strongly as about the people in
that locker room as he has at any point
in his career he fixed his relationships
with gouda kunst and murphy and his
relationship's always been good with
merc with uh with lafore
you know but like if there are
those you know phony years in the back
of his deal then yeah you would have to
think about it and hey if i'm the
packers here's the other part of it like
tampa did that with a bunch of contracts
to create a two-year window with tom
brady
wouldn't you say they would say it was
worth it now like even if they have to
tear it down they won a championship so
like if this means creating a two or
three year window with aaron rodgers and
maybe he walks after that
like i
if i'm the packers that's that's 100
percent worth it to go and chase another
championship when you haven't won one
and what is it 12 years now it's been 12
years since they won that first one with
aaron rodgers
wow so you think we're back in like the
story of the new league year of 2023 is
gonna be where roger's free agency
i'm not saying that i don't think so no
i i mean like again like i i have no
i have no like
i've heard nowhere that like this is
like the precursor to rogers saying
goodbye again
uh but i mean you can look at their
roster you know what i mean like and say
like yeah like there's a very real
two-year window you can look at david
bactiari's age devante adam's age
you can look at like how
that's a really great football situation
now
you know but two three years down the
line it might look a little bit
different based on how some of these
contracts are built and by the way
here's the other thing i mean these guys
can always force their way out i mean
that's one thing that we're learning now
right like russell wilson didn't really
have to do anything like he could just
sit on his hands and let it happen
um that's becoming more common now as
quarterbacks sort of accumulate more
power
so
alvarez here a few minutes left with him
from sports illustrator right here on
the rich eisen show so why did it have
to happen in seattle
what happened because russ again that's
the type of guy homegrown walter payton
man of the year go hawks i mean
and and i i would never have imagined as
he's going through that ascension uh
from um you know
pete carroll uh seattle seahawk um you
know face of franchise to yeah he's gone
before he's 34. so what happened
i think it goes back to the last
contract negotiation um you know and i i
think you can actually take it back to
do you remember the stories out there
that the um and this is the year that
baker mayfield josh allen and sam
darnold were in the draft in 18 that the
seahawks had explored trading russell
wilson to cleveland
and um with the idea they were going to
you know wind up with the number one
overall pick and take one of the
quarterbacks like
that like i like from what i've heard
that stuck with him you know and that
was part of the reason why the next year
he had a no trade clause negotiated into
his contract
so
he could control where he was going to
go next and i think all the way around
there was a feeling after that
negotiation because it was a difficult
one
this is going to be the last contract he
does in seattle like right like this is
going to be the last one and we'll
figure it out somewhere along the line
um but let's try to make the most of it
now and then this that's going to be
that
and you know i think because of some of
the animosity that it built up over the
years you saw some of the back and forth
last year
and this year was a little bit different
that like
and i think russell felt like this was
going to be it for him
um and he was content to say like let's
just let this play out
and you know i think over the last i'd
say
month or so
um you know talks started to heat up i
think they've been talking to denver
since the beginning of february
and um you know it's just kind of built
and built and built
and i think for the seahawks the main
thing was you look at the roster it's
like okay
if we know we've got no more than two
years left with russell wilson because
there's two years left on this deal
do we think we can get the roster back
into a place where we can win fast
enough
that it's going to be worth it to keep
him around knowing that we're not going
to give him another contract
and
like i i think you just look at that
then you just oppose it against the
trade value which if you've got a guy
with two years left on his contract he's
more valuable than a guy with one year
left on his contract and what you can
get for him
and so i think for seattle it was
everything that had built up over the
years
was just it was it was all right like
now is the time now is when it makes
sense the same way detroit traded
stafford last year with two years left
in his deal and then i think russell
really wanted to go to a place where
everything was built around him you know
and it was going to be a very
quarterback centric operation because he
never really had that in seattle
and um you know denver historically has
has done that you know go back to the
years of john elway obviously with
peyton manning um you know i think
they're able to afford him
sort of what he was looking for in that
way and a lot of ways rich was what's
really interesting about this is i think
like the root of some of this was like
aaron rodgers and russell wilson last
year saying looking over at tampa and
looking at what tom brady said there
had there and said like give me that
and i think
aaron rodgers has sort of been able to
leverage his way into having that
without having to leave green bay and
now i think russell wilson's got it in
denver yeah i was kind of likening it to
uh
roethlisberger
um and cower having a different dynamic
than tomlin
and roethlisberger
that you know that to pete russ was
always that kid who he drafted or at
least in russ's mind he was always you
know the kid that that pete um drafted
and nurtured always compete and he
competed and he got in and um and now
russ is going to be the og
that everybody went to go get for the
new coach what a totally different
quarterback
coaching dynamic for him and it'll be
fascinating to play out and see if it
works right yeah the context of it is
important and i think you nailed it like
it's
you know like all the history there like
the legion of boom right like and and
how there was friction between russell
and those guys
and russell's place in the organization
and how russell thought things should be
run versus how he thought things should
be run like and i i think those guys are
going to look back on their years
together fondly don't get me wrong here
i don't think this is like a hatred
thing but your history is your history
you know and i think like that history
sort of weighed everyone down over the
last couple of years and so
now the seahawks get to go and rebuild
the roster and they got draft capital to
do it
and russell comes out of this and again
like his entry point to denver is so
different than his entry point to
seattle
and um you know he arrives there sort of
as the man
and you know i think he arrives in sort
of a partnership with george payton and
with the samuel hackett you know those
guys are still relatively new there too
um and you know he can again like be the
guy who can help bring along a jerry
judy who can help maybe take cortland's
son to another level who can maybe get
more out of kj hamler like all of that
and he can attract other guys in from
the outside
um you know and so like i just think
like you said like the context of the
relationship between team and player is
much different in this case which i
think is exactly what russell was
looking for last thing for you a new
rich eisen show segment and a concept or
idea that uh like everything else born
here
we just thought of on the spot uh tb12
heat check heat check uh on a scale of
zero to 12.
zero is um you know uh what's the line
i've been using uh jello shots with rita
moreno okay correct where he got no is
no not thinking at all about coming back
and 12 is he's definitely coming back
where do you where do you stand on that
scale
yeah i like so i'll be firmly on the
fence i'll say seven
why the reason why
is like i
i don't think he knows how he's gonna
feel in like june and july and august
and i you know i think i've said this to
you before rich but
it's a much different thing like asking
a guy for a 12-month commitment right a
12-month commitment to play football
which is what you'd be doing now versus
like a team coming to him in august and
saying
can you do it for the next five months
those are two different things so it
didn't surprise me if he didn't keep
himself in shape and i'll be interested
to see if you know their
tmz uh photos you know in may and june
and him working out at some high school
and with his helmet on and everything
else uh
you know because i do think you know
like there's
i i don't know that like that thing in
the back of his head um you know that he
has not done like i don't know that's
gone away yet
albert thanks for the time greatly
appreciate it and just in time uh
michigan blew a 13-point uh halftime
lead and got bounced by indiana so
congratulations
it is indeed
are you guys out then do you think you
make the tournament still or not don't
know man uh but i just it literally just
ended and um
thankfully though the handshake is going
without incident
and that's the best part about it so
well i'm sure you're happy to be talking
to me at a time like that you know what
albert good luck to you along the way
thanks for the time greatly appreciated
brother thank you so much thanks rachel
good to see you at the combine that's
albert brewer here everybody on the rich
eisen show hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that watch more
right here